that's my secret it's not unusual for
hollywood actors like mark ruffalo to
weigh in on domestic politics
but why does the star of the hulk care
about chile
specifically sunday's referendum on
whether or not to approve an ambitious
new constitution
earlier this week roofalo tweeted that
the proposal represents hope for the
world
one that has
more equality and
humanity and thoughtfulness in it
and so i know a lot of great people have
worked on this and um
the uh
the world's looking uh towards you as a
model to address
the changing climate and the need for
greater democracy
so lots of love and we are watching
closely not just actors but hundreds of
intellectuals scientists
environmentalists human rights activists
economists and feminists from every
continent have endorsed chile's draft
constitution which they describe as
cutting edge
one of them is professor ulrich brandt
the constitution opens
a space to rethink
how the economic model the social model
the role of indigenous peoples the role
of women etc etc and should be in a
society of the 21st century
the constitution would be the first to
specifically acknowledge climate change
and environmental protection and
guarantee gender parity
it also introduces structural political
and social reforms such as guaranteed
health education and pensions as well as
broad recognition of indigenous rights
but while many international observers
may applaud all this plenty of chileans
like these plan to vote against the new
constitution there are many reasons from
disinformation about what it really says
to fears that it is too radical too
vague and that it will not guarantee
stability in this country
yes sebastian edwards says the devil is
in the details it's a very uneven never
tried
in the world political system which will
create a lot of instability and
uncertainty
and if there is uncertainty there's no
investment
the constitution has polarized chile
even as the majority agree that this
socially unequal country needs change
how much change though seems to be the
issue
lucia newman al jazeera santiago